>> JASON: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY,
TRUMP VERSUS THE SWAMP.
ELITISTS WHO HAVE A DISGUST FOR
AMERICA'S HEART LAND.
THE BELOVED ACTOR CHRIS PRATT,
WELL KNOWN FOR HONORING THE
TROOPS AND MAKING SURPRISE
VISITS TO SICK CHILDREN IS UNDER
ATTACK.
HE GAVE A SPEECH TO YOUNG PEOPLE
AT THE MTV MOVIE AND TV AWARDS
IN JUNE TELLING THEM, QUOTE, GOD
IS REAL.
GOD LOVES YOU.
GOD WANTS THE BEST FOR YOU.
BELIEVE THAT.
I DO.
AND LEARN TO PRAY.
IT'S EASY AND IT'S SO GOOD FOR
YOUR SOUL, END QUOTE.
LOOKS LIKE THE HOLLYWOOD STAR
HAS ANGERED THE LEFT EVEN
FURTHER.
A TV GUIDE EDITOR LAMBASTED HIM
AS PROBLEMATIC FOR BEING A LOVER
OF HUNTING AND RAISING LAMBS.
THE GUY RAN AN ARTICLE HOW TO
LOVE CHRIS PRATT WITHOUT HATING
YOURSELF.
IT TAKES ISSUE WITH PRATT'S FARM
TO TABLE LIFESTYLE.
HE EVEN EATS MEAT, OH MY
GOODNESS!
HERE TO DISCUSS THE LIBERAL'S
DISCONNECT WITH THE MAIN STREAM
AMERICA IS TURNING POINT USA
FOUNDER CHARLIE KIRK AND TRUMP
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER MADISON
JESIATO.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, CHARLIE, THE
DISCONNECT HERE COULD NOT BE
FURTHER.
CHRIS PRATT IS SAYING, I LIKE
HUNTING, I LIKE GOD AND I LIKE
PRAYING.
WHY IS HE CONSTANTLY UNDER
ATTACK?
>> THIS IS SO IMPORTANT, JASON,
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE SEEN THAT
IT'S NO LONGER A POLITICAL
DIVIDE IN OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S BECOMING A CULTURAL DIVIDE.
IT USED TO BE THINGS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY USED TO
EMBRACE.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IN THE '60S
ARCH '70S AND '80S USED TO BE IN
FEAR OF GOD THAT KNEW THE
LIFESTYLE OF MAINLAND USA.
NO LONGER.
IT IS A PARTY WHICH POLITICS HAS
GONE TOWARD THIS CULTURAL
RELATIVISM.
THERE IS NO GOD, HUNTING IS
GONE, MEAT IS EVIL.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS ABSURD.
THIS IS THE LIFESTYLE YOU'LL
FIND IN MANHATTAN AND MALIBU.
THERE'S A MIDDLE PART OF THE
COUNTRY THAT'S REJECTING THIS
WHOLE HEARTEDLY.
YOU SEE THIS WITH CHRIS PRATT.
HE'S JUST A GOOD RED BLOODED
AMERICAN WHO BELIEVES IN GOD AND
COUNTRY AND IS GETTING TARGETED
BY THESE HOLLYWOOD AND MANHATTAN
ELITES.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SPEAK OUT IN
HOLLYWOOD BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> JASON: CHRIS PRATT IS AN
ENTERTAINING ENTERTAINER.
HIS MOVIES, HE PUTS A SMILE ON
HIS FACE.
HE NOW HAS A TARGET ON HIS BACK
BECAUSE HE LIKES TO HUNT, HE
RAISES LAMBS THAT HE ENDS UP
EATING.
HE'S LIVING THE WAY THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS LIVE BUT HE NOW HAS A
TARGET ON HIS BACK.
>> I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK PEOPLE
HAVE BIGGER THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT CHRIS PRATT'S EATING.
MOST PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEIR FOOD COMES TO WORST
PLACES.
CHRIS IS A GREAT GUY.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THAT CHRIS IS
A HUNTER.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT CHRIS IS A
CHRISTIAN AND IS NOT LIBERAL, SO
HE DOESN'T FIT IN WITH THE
MEDIA.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
HE'S AMAZING ON SCREEN.
HE'S WORKED WITH SPECIAL
OLYMPIC.
HE'S RAISED MONIES FOR FAMILIES
OF CHILDREN WITH CANNER.
HE'S SOMEONE THAT SOMEONE IN
THIS COUNTRY CAN LOOK UP TO.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO TAKES TIME TO
DO THINGS FOR OTHERS.
HE SENT ME A MESSAGE
CONGRATULATING ME.
I HAVE BEEN IMPRESSED WITH HIM.
I WISH THE LIBERALS SHOULD STOP
SHOWING THEIR BIAS.
GUESS WHAT?
HE'S SOMEONE THAT WE SHOULD LOOK
TO, NOT SOMEONE WE SHOULD BE
ATTACKING.
>> JASON: CHARLIE, THE LIBERALS
TAKE THIS APPROACH AND WANT TO
GO AFTER PEOPLE THAT HUNT, THEY
PRAY AND BELIEVE IN GOD.
HOW IN THE WORLD ARE THEY GONNA
GROW THEIR PARTY IF THEY THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S REPRESENTATIVE OF
AMERICA?
>> WELL, PART OF THEIR POLITICAL
STRATEGY IS TO TRY TO ALLOW 10
TO 15 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO
THE COUNTRY, NATURALIZE THEM,
GET THE RIGHT TO VOTE, THEREFORE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO WIN BACK
MIDDLE AMERICA.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS CYNICAL.
DEMOCRATS ARE ON THEIR WAY TO DO
THAT.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO REALIZE WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A CULTURE WAR IN OUR
COUNTRY.
ARE WE STILL A COUNTRY THAT
BELIEVES IN IN GOD WE TRUST AND
LIBERTY?
THESE ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL
VALUES OF OUR COUNTRY THAT MADE
AMERICA THE GREATEST COUNTRY AND
GREATEST CULTURE TO EXIST.
IT'S, WE HAVE GONE SO FAR
OUTSIDE OF THE RAILS OF REALITY
WHEN SOMEONE LIKE CHRIS PRATT IS
ATTACKED.